earlier today i spoke with dr nash about
a long-term solution
dr nash it is always great to have you
on the show and you know many of us have
heard of the
freshman 15 and last year some of us
have been dealing with the
quarantine 19 some weight gain because
of the pandemic
something very interesting though
because you say kind of the current
covenant
restrictions are kind of almost
hindering our weight loss
yeah absolutely um so the unfortunate
thing is now that we've had about a year
of statistics to look at
um what we're seeing is large amounts of
weight gain in a majority of the
population so we have more than 54
percent of the com
of the country now reporting some kind
of weight gain average weight gain is 20
pounds or more now
and then we're seeing bad behaviors
developing on top of it things like
restricted movement and snacking in fact
68
of the country in a recent study said
that they were snacking more and they
couldn't seem to get it under control
so over the past year with with coba 19
and a pandemic
um have you dealt with any clients
during the past year and have they had
successes because it's a different world
that we're living in when it comes to
being able to diet and exercise
yeah actually um i did have a client in
may which is meredith
she went through my program and this was
at the height of the pandemic when
really everything was shut down the only
thing she could do in terms of exercise
was walking
she turned around and lost an impressive
14 pounds in 30 days
but i think more important the visual of
her change is
is critical because you can see how all
of that weight came off
from the belly and it's that belly fat
that indicates we're dealing with some
kind of damage underneath the surface
and it's more than just walking though
it's and you're going deep
into um you're finding the true source
of the problem when it comes to when it
comes to weight gain
and getting rid of this stubborn fat too
that's a hard area to get rid of
yeah and that's the key to it right if
i'm dealing with stubborn fat either the
weight loss is slow or non-existent or
if i'm seeing that weight gain around
the belly
that is my body signaling to me that
something under the surface is going on
and that's what we have to get to the
root cause of incorrect
in order for you to see the kind of
weight loss that we talk about in my
program
so what's the fix how can you help
people right so
normally um my evaluations are 97
when people talk to me what we need to
do is an online evaluation now
when people can't come to my office so
that i can determine
what the problem is and help them
develop a program that will not only fix
it
but will accelerate their weight loss
and get their body to hold the weight
eating up to 3 000 calories a day
and dr nash every time you come on the
show you always have a special for
us what do you have for us this week so
we have about 10 evaluations
where it's 90 off it's less than 10
it will be completely online and virtual
but because i only have the 10 spots
available we do have it on the website
that we're showing on the screen that's
the best way to lock in your spot
but this way we get to talk to each
other in real time
even though it's virtually so that i can
find out what the problem is and then
help you come up with a plan to solve it